every mcu project comes with at least a
few easter eggs that not at the comic
book history that inspired them from
halloween costumes to big band music
here are the best vision easter eggs
you're going to find in the mcu
marvel studios has a long tradition of
simultaneously poking fun at their own
characters and paying homage by giving
us glimpses of those heroes and goofier
yet more comic book accurate versions of
their costumes
edward norton's bruce banner passes on
the purple pants betty ross buys him in
2008's the incredible hulk
jessica jones is less than thrilled at
the idea of her more comics accurate
attire in netflix's jessica jones
and luke cage made its hero's science
experiment garb into his 70s comic book
outfit
heck in 2011's captain america the first
avenger steve rogers wears a clownish
comics accurate version of his costume
before getting an upgrade
in episode 6 of wandavision we get a
similar treatment for paul bettany's
vision
bowing to wanda's wishes vision dresses
for halloween is a mexican wrestler
although it might be more accurate to
say that he's dressed as a comic's
accurate vision
in fact almost the whole family rocks
their comics accurate looks
while comics fans might recognize the
outfits right away it's a little less
obvious to the characters on wandavision
the false piatro makes a number of
guesses at what vision is supposed to be
sweet costume bro ham-in-law let me
guess uh
traffic light half-shucked corn
a booger one of the more interesting
vision easter eggs we've seen comes in
don't touch that dial the second episode
of wand division
wanda is in her living room when she
hears something crash outside
in her front yard she finds what appears
to be a remote control helicopter in the
bushes
later in the fourth episode we learned
this is actually a sword drone
transformed by the hex
the helicopter is one of the first
things in color we see in wandavision's
black and white world
it's red and gold with some metallic
silver mixed in similar to the color
scheme of tony stark's iron man armor
the number 57 is on its side and the
sword symbol is painted on the front
how is this a vision easter egg well the
most obvious sign is the number 57 on
the side of the helicopter which matches
the number for the comic in which vision
premieres
1968's avengers number 57 it's also
probably not a mistake that the sitcom
most heavily referenced in wandevision's
second episode
is bewitched which premiered in 1964 and
was still going strong in 1968 when
vision's first appearance showed up on
comic book spinners
plus the iron man colors referenced tony
stark one of vision's creators
it also arrives with what sounds like an
accidental crash and much of the rest of
the episode involves vision
malfunctioning after swallowing a piece
of chewing gum
we first meet vision in 2015's avengers
age of ultron
but in a sense we kind of met him four
years earlier in captain america the
first avenger
before steve rogers goes through the
experiment that makes him a super
soldier he visits the world's fair where
among other things he sees what appears
to be an inner man in a red costume kept
in a transparent tube
above the man is a sign that reads
phineas horton presents the synthetic
man
this is jim hammond the original human
torch long before the introduction of
the fantastic four
marvel comics had an earlier version of
the human torch who was an android
created by dr phineas horton
in fact it's a battle between the
original human torch and the submariner
that creates a concept of the marvel
universe
when they meet in fight to 1940s marvel
mystery comics number eight it's the
first time
two of marvel's heroes are shown to
occupy the same narrative
in 1975's avengers number 135 the vision
discovers that ultron created him using
the brainwave patterns of the hero
wonder man
and the body of jim hammond in other
words what on the surface seems like
just a human torch easter egg in the
first avenger
is also a vision easter egg in fact
before the premiere of wand division
some fans were theorizing this might be
the key to how vision would be
resurrected
as soon as fans started catching
glimpses of images from one division it
was obvious that the miniseries was
taking part of its inspiration from a
few different comics in vision's long
history
the two most obvious inspirations are
1982 and 1985's division in scarlet
witch
two mini-series that see the odd couple
move to the suburbs of new jersey to
start a life together
another obvious inspiration for
wandavision is 2016's vision series
which sees the eponymous synthezoid
building himself an entire family of
synthetics all with names like his own
beginning with b
there's his wife virginia as well as his
two kids viv and vin
with the family he builds from scratch
vision tries to live an idyllic
existence in a quiet suburb but it isn't
meant to be
they even eventually have their own
synthesoid dog named sparky
built from the brain of a dog who
accidentally electrocutes itself while
unearthing the corpse of a dead
supervillain in vision's backyard
just as wandavision sparky is killed in
on a very special episode the poor pooch
of the comic book is also killed though
by a different character
paul bettany even confirmed the
connection between the disney plus show
and the recent vision-centric series
speaking of variety in january 2021 the
actor said the series was pitched to him
as a mash-up between two comic book
series
the vision and the 2005 mini-series
house of m
in the mid-credits scene to episode 8 we
find director hayward standing
triumphantly before a reassembled vision
there's one major difference though the
synthezoid is white from head to toe
while the visual is striking it isn't
the first time the world has seen white
vision
during his time as avengers chairman
vision secretly develops a plan to take
over all of the world's computer systems
using them to force peace and security
on the world after being confronted by
his teammates in 1985's avengers number
254
vision relents and soon afterwards
leaves the team but some people aren't
happy with the synthozoid roaming free
in 1989's west coast avengers number 44
vision's colleagues learn that he's been
kidnapped by a team made up of rogue
government agents from different
countries
that his body has been disassembled and
his memory has been erased to ensure
that he doesn't retain any of the
sensitive information he had access to
in the 1985 avengers story
hank pym is able to reassemble vision in
the following issue but he's nothing
like the avenger his teammates remember
because of extensive damage to his
circulatory system his skin
is bone white more importantly he's lost
all sense of emotion and humanity
the white vision of wandavision isn't
the only callback to the time when the
synthazoid becomes a lot less colorful
in the comics
towards the end of avengers infinity war
thanos completes his quest by ripping
the mind stone from vision's head
killing the avenger as soon as he does
all the color drains from vision's body
turning him gray
while obviously gray and white aren't
the same in both cases we get all other
color leaving the synthesiods form
along with being a white vision easter
egg this was one of many references in
infinity war to one of the comics that
most heavily influenced the film
the 1991 mini-series infinity gauntlet
when the small army of superheroes
assault thanos and infinity gauntlet
number four vision is among them
and it's the emotionless white vision
who thanos kills in the battle
perhaps the most emotionally powerful
vision related easter egg in the mcu
comes in one of the flashbacks of
wandavision's eighth episode
barging her way into sword headquarters
wanda demands her right to claim
vision's body
as she approaches his disassembled form
and tries to get some sense of his
presence with her powers wanda says
i can't feel you
[Music]
this is a call back to the first
division's two deaths at the end of
avengers infinity war
with time running out and thanos on his
way vision convinces wanda to use her
powers to destroy the mind stone in
order to keep it out of thanos grasp
but there's no way to do this without
also killing vision
as wanda begins the process vision tries
to comfort her
you could never hurt me
i just feel you sadly these turn out to
be some of vision's last words to wanda
while thanos turns back time in order to
restore the mind stone it's only to rip
the stone from the synthazoid's head and
kill him a second time
as soon as vision came to life in
avengers age of ultron comic book fans
were wondering about whether or not
they'd see a big screen adaptation of
wanda and vision's romantic relationship
it wouldn't be until the following
year's captain america civil war that we
got to see any kind of real romance
developing between the pair
but age of ultron gave us an enticing
hint at more to come
having left her post to destroy ultron
toward the end of the film wanda misses
her chance to board the helicarrier and
is still on the airborne chunk of
sokovia when it hurtles toward earth
luckily vision flies through the debris
to rescue her the visual of the
synthazoid grabbing wanda and carrying
her away had to give plenty of fans
chills
it's particularly meaningful when you
realize there's a good chance vision
already has some semblance of attraction
toward her
in order to have any idea where she is
among all the rubble and flying debris
he must have been keeping tabs on her
and why would he be doing that
unless there's something there that
catches his eye in a list of vision
easter eggs it would be criminal to
forget the faux tv ads featured in
wandavision
and the one that most heavily references
the synthezoid is the very first of the
commercials we see in the mini-series
in episode 1 the story of wandavision's
black and white world is interrupted by
a commercial for the toastmate 2000 made
by stark industries
granted vision is definitely not the
only character being referenced here
when the ad's housewife starts the toast
mates we hear a sound identical to the
noise that iron man's repulsors make in
the films plus the matching pieces of
toast are one of the episode's many
references to the twins who will soon
arrive
billy and tommy but vision is the
character who brings them all together
like the toaster he's part machine he's
wanda's mate and like the toastmate 2000
one of his creators was a stark
one easter egg and avengers age of
ultron doesn't reference the synthezoid
directly but instead it's a little nod
to one of his real world creators
when the avengers clash with the
combined forces of ultron and the
maximoff twins wanda uses her telepathic
powers to force the heroes into a
nightmare world
in the case of captain america the super
soldier finds himself sent back to a
world war ii era dance hall
where we get flashes of a celebration
it's tough to spot but the band keeping
everything hopping is named after a
marvel comics veteran
on the bass drum is the name the roy
thomas players
among other things roy thomas was the
marvel comics editor-in-chief
after stan lee and he's one of the two
people along with the late artist john
buscema responsible for creating both
vision and ultron
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite comic book easter eggs are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you